you
good morning everybody welcome to day
two of the Microsoft Research Latin
America faculty summit very excited to
welcome you to this day it's sort of the
crescendo of our event jam-packed I know
it's early but if we don't get started
now we're going to be later later later
all day and then we'll miss the party
tonight which is the most important part
of the entire event so no way are we
missing that one I'm really excited to
be here and to introduce our next
speaker Judith Bishop I've known for a
long time and is an amazing colleague so
let me get my notes so I can make sure
and rehearse and bio she is the director
of computer science in microsoft
research in the united states in redmond
her role is to create strong links
between Microsoft's research groups and
universities on a global scale she
encourages projects conferences and
engages directly in research programs as
well I've worked with her on a project
called try F sharp for doing some
exciting things they're actually touch
develop code hunt the BBC micro bit
which I believe is also being discussed
at this event and latest is the quantum
simulator called liquid she now drives
the Open Source Initiative and her
expertise is primarily in programming
languages and distributed systems with a
very actually a very strong practical
bias which is pretty neat after her
degrees her undergraduate degrees in
South Africa she received her PhD from
Southampton in the UK and then was a
professor University of Pretoria in
South Africa she's an ACM distinguished
educator has received the ifip
silvercorp award among others and she is
also a fellow of the british computer
society and the Royal Society of South
Africa please give
warm welcome to Judith Bishop
good morning everyone I'm delighted to
be here this latum summit and I want to
thank very much evil in Vieques Jaime
Puente and of course Roy Zimmerman for
inviting me and setting everything up so
well so when would you not want
something for free that's going to make
you friends and actually is going to
make what you do better that's actually
what people think open source is all
about I'm going to tell you much more
deeply what it is and how it affects us
in industry in particular actually in
Microsoft because that's what I know
best but I will bring in more general
terms from industry as I've seen it
operating among my colleagues in other
companies as well I'm going to spend
half the talk on that part and then most
of the talk the other half on Microsoft
researchers offerings in the open source
arena so let's get going open source
myths open source is often equated with
big software which is in the public
domain and so anyone can use it or just
freeware in other words it's stuff
that's free and therefore it's open
source or it's not enforced by anyone
and some of those words are good for
industry and some of them are not good
for industry same for academics of
course but generally speaking these are
nice things to have what is it from the
point of view of Microsoft or from
industry they jump straight into the
legal aspects and they say actually it's
also a licensing model and they're a lot
of aspects to the licensing
I have to admit straight off I don't
understand these completely first of all
I don't have to because when you are in
a great big company you have a large arm
of people who are responsible for
handling the licensing and the licensing
can get very complex the main word to
retailers on the second line you get a
license that gives you the right to copy
modify and redistribute the code and
that is the most important thing all
right then can you make money out of it
and so on well depends on the license
and it depends on variations but the
point is that you can copy the code you
can modify it and you can redistribute
what you've done as a new piece of code
it also comes with no representations or
warranties and that's interesting so
unlike software which is sold by a
company like Microsoft or by Apple for
example or Oracle who actually sell
software when it's software like this
you can actually distribute it and say
use it I'm not going to support it and
and that is a little scary when you
think about it of course you can support
it and there are fantastic models of
this which are backed with open source
software as we know IBM have been very
successful at doing this with their red
hat and so on redistribution also
triggers certain other licensing
obligations and that's where it starts
going down a chain and the whole
licensing thing is a mixture I'll give
you one good example of that as we go on
what is much more interesting
from our point of view here is that open
source is also a development methodology
it changes completely the way that
software in a company is developed so
here are just six ways in which software
has to change if we are going to use
open source software inside a company
and send it out as well we need to
regard our users as developers or put it
the other way the people who are
contributing to the open-source software
are also our users we have to take into
account their desires and their wishes
very early on in the process and that
makes a big difference to features to
requirement specifications and so on
early release you you don't have
releases way out there three-quarters
away three quarters of a year away you
keep releasing frequent integration and
so on open source also enforces very
high modularity of code because you need
to put things into smaller groups which
can be open source separately or which
you replace with open source software
separately so that's actually a good
thing as you know in code design hi
modalert modularity is regarded as a
good thing and then dynamic decision
making that can be a bit tricky in a
company where you have large software
groups some software group seed
companies are hundreds of people and if
you are taking decisions based on what
somebody out there said or submitted to
your software Reaper
could be difficult it could disrupt it
could be disruptive so all of these
change the way you think and the way
that you develop your code so this is
what's been going on inside companies
for a while and certainly with inside
Microsoft you can regard it as having
three actors they're the creators of the
software they're the users of the
software and then they're that
contributors once you've created and
you've used it and everything is in this
great big open source repository so
that's the word that people talk about a
lot the repository and at different
times industrial companies will engage
in all three of those so sometimes
companies will be using other people's
software they will find some neat little
algorithm or some neat little piece of
code and they will insert it into a new
piece of software and they will use the
open source and contribute to open
source all of those happen now you might
ask about that last one why would a
company encourage you allow even their
employees to contribute in company time
to open source what's in it for them
well it turns out that this is part of
the whole ecosystem of open-source
development that if you contribute you
become part of the community and then
eventually in time you get back from the
community what you put in moreover
developers are very keen to do this and
that probably that last one is one of
the hardest ones
to step over using yes we'll use what
you've got and we'll use it for free but
that's easy we'll create stuff and you
can have it if we don't feel that it's
worth too much in IP but the third one
is company time of employees and that
has to be done as well if you want to be
really part of the whole open-source
ecosystem so all of those and we'll see
how they are done so if we're doing all
of that what's in it for the software
industry and I'm going to tell you
straight away that I did not write the
slide this was written for me by our
people in the Microsoft open-source a
part of the company so we have a special
part of the company that assists and
promotes the open-source aspect of what
we do so you can understand the words
here are a little bit promotional first
of all it gives us speed if we're using
other people software we can go faster
to market by getting comments earlier on
the software we can find out that our
software is more robust what that really
means is other people are getting the
bugs out for us and that's a good thing
as you know in open-source people submit
bug reports to the repos and that's a
good thing if you get a trusted
community out there who like your
software who want to submit bug reports
that's great interoperability
interoperability is something which a
company like Microsoft is very very keen
on we want to make sure that our
software will run on all platforms and
then many ways of doing this obviously
open source is one of them
and it certainly gives us business
growth because we are not just running
on the Windows platform we can then run
on other platforms as well give you some
examples of those in a moment but
through the open source community we can
get that expertise going and then the
thriving technology ecosystem out there
I have to say and you probably know this
already that young people in particular
are very attracted to open source
software they feel that it's a place
where even if they don't contribute they
are allowed to contribute so there's a
freedom there and it is a domain where
one wants to be and a forward-looking
company like Microsoft certainly wants
to play in this in this game and it just
gives you more choice more competition
and that's where we would like to be so
our leader and CEO satya nadella made a
statement last April so this was April
2015 that industry embraces open source
in fact he said Microsoft embraces open
source and I went to check on this and i
found that of course it is true every
company is doing open source and i
checked up on various reports by
independent observers of the yeah just
off the ecosystem out there rather than
looking on the websites of the companies
which do tend to show all their
different offerings as you can see here
you can see that we have the big
companies like Apple and IBM Facebook
and so on they all have their open
source software
but it's not just those it's the next
level down that are also using open
source to promote what they do and to
develop what they do and so that's
interesting and there's some very big
names there like GE EMC I think there's
a MC lab here and maybe they even some
MC people in the audience here VMware
verizon is a telephone company and
Internet company in the u.s. so it's
pervasive people are relying on it and
it's not going to go away right when
actually did open source start inside
Microsoft it's very interesting to find
out when now you won't be able to see
too much detail on this slide that
doesn't matter what's interesting is
that it's it happened more than 10 years
ago and we had this trajectory of
involvement in open source very slowly
parts of the company we're starting to
move into open source and you can see
the little linux penguin there in the
middle and at that stage we decided we
were going to have some kind of Linux
and they were other ones like nodejs
dotnet that's the purple one up on the
top there until larger and larger parts
of the software that was on offer or
that we wanted to incorporate or that we
bought were involved in open source and
these were made announced as they went
in bits and pieces bits and pieces until
eventually we and it came to that
conclusion which as I told you such a
and came gave last year
how does the open source actually work
inside microsoft itself well they're
different ways one of the ones is that
we can incorporate open source inside
existing large tools now you might know
about visual studio visual studio is our
environmental software editor that is
used for the development of software and
inside of that is an open source section
which is called Python tools and Python
tools is for development of Python and
it was brought over from the Python
community as an open source piece of
software that Python tools are open
source when visual studio is shipped as
a actual piece of code it is shipped
with this open source and as a result if
you look inside and you can actually you
will find that there are about a hundred
and fifty different licenses which are
shipped with it so this is the licensing
aspect which I told you about because
different pieces of those Python tools
and other pieces which are inside Visual
Studio which are open source have to
have their attributive licenses shipped
with them most users never see that but
it's very very important that they're
there the other part of visual studio
which is interesting I think for all
academics in the audience and I think
most of you are is that there is a code
version it's called the code edition of
Visual Studio it's a bit tricky that
word code it doesn't mean code it means
the code edition is the academic edition
actually which is free and that one is
free to students and that one is also
available on Mac on Linux and free to
all students and in that you will also
find this open-source software so all in
all you can have hybrid systems another
example of this which I'll be telling
you about later is where the company can
actually make a lot of money out of a
particular piece of code and yet have
open source in it but not all of it and
and that is what makes you realize that
open source is not giving away all the
IP it's just giving away the software
but using and developing in the open
source model now openness is a word
which microsoft has used a lot and
openness is the making axis of standard
technology what they say really happen
so it's not always possible to have
different versions for all the different
platforms I've just mentioned available
but one way of doing it is to take
things to a meta level and to leverage
something like the azure a cloud and
then what you can do is you can put the
software like the Windows software or a
Bunter software or any of that inside
the cloud and then put it up so this
isn't really open source development but
it is making sure that we have open
software it's it's a slightly different
version
it's made much more easy by the
availability of open source software on
repos public Reapers which are out there
so one example i'd like to mention is
the windows sdk which for facebook and
we probably a lot of you use facebook i
know that i have to use it to make sure
that i can keep in touch with my family
and there's a windows sdk for facebook
and that is available open source so
Facebook itself is not a product from
Microsoft but this little SDK is and you
can incorporate that into whatever it is
that you want to do and that was made
available and you can see that these you
won't be able to read it but it was
developed by the windows develop a
platform team early in july last year
and the open-source team at microsoft
released it as an implementation of the
facebook sdk so they made that so that
things could be easier and people could
use on different platforms what needed
to be done right now actually this week
in Texas there's the biggest open source
conference called Oskan and Microsoft
had a planeload of people going to that
conference it also had one of the
keynotes there by Joseph sirach who is
the corporate vice president of one of
our units and the whole idea was around
Microsoft using and developing in the
open source arena so these would be the
people who make these kind of things
happen and they certainly were there to
hire people and to expose what is being
done in the open source
so I'd like to switch now to what's
going on in Microsoft Research which of
course is where we come from those of us
who are here talking to you over these
couple of days often we have pictures of
buildings but I decide to don't have a
picture of the trees outside Microsoft
which are very beautiful in all in all
seasons so Microsoft Research was
established in 1991 and those of you who
good at arithmetic will know that that
meets that with 25 years old this year
and we are happy to be having an
anniversary over a thousand scientists
we have nine different units of course
one of them is here in Brazil and and we
have 24 research areas they keep
changing but if you look on the website
today it says they're 24 now inside this
enormous organization there is a lot
going on in open source the problem was
as you can see that it was very
difficult for people to find out what
was going on you could go to any project
page of an area that you were interested
in and you could look up a project it
was not really evident whether it was
open source or not open source and so on
so that's why we started within
Microsoft this initiative to really
expose and make clear what is microsoft
researchers a contribution to the open
source environment since 2014 there's
been a huge trend towards researchers
open sourcing their software we now have
over 50 projects now that sounds perhaps
like a small number but it's quite a
large number because one of the things
about
it's an open source project is that you
can't just put it out there and leave it
it's got to be looked after projects
need to be curated projects that are
open source will start to get
contributions and you need to look at
those contributions you will eventually
if your project is popular start
building a community and their various
ways of controlling that community if
you're a single person you might have to
say whoa I can't take that many
contributions but on the other hand if
it is a very popular project maybe you
can get more people to help you with it
the projects are not just for academics
that definitely aimed at other
developers they're aimed at our internal
Microsoft products as well so there's a
huge variety and the way I want to go
through this is to show you the example
of some of our products that we've got
out there our projects and in the
research showcase you can come and look
at more of them so as I said the way we
dealt with us as we set up this portal
and the other thing and now you're going
to hear me mention this word for the
first time is we decided that it was
good to try to move to a single
repository which turns out to be github
many of you will equate open source with
github but github is not the only place
where open source can be they were and
are other places where you can put open
source it just turns out that github has
become probably at the moment the most
popular and Microsoft has a special
relationship with github now we have
people who work on both sides they come
and work at Microsoft and help us and we
help them get
have an academic arm as well and we are
very good friends with them they'll help
us with promotion of farm products so
what exactly have we got well we've got
tools in specialized domains so here are
the 12 domains we've got verification
cryptography visualization programming
cloud computing education of course
artificial intelligence hardware systems
science documents interesting one that
but we'll see why and society and then
from those we can pick out and classify
all of the open source software we have
and then you can go and look at it and
this is what it looks like so you get a
list of the projects and you can then
from there go and have a look at what a
project is and whether it would be of
use to you so instead of going to all 50
if you're in artificial intelligence you
can see while at the moment they're ten
but next week there might be 12 and we
also list them not in alphabetical order
which might sound but strange but we
list them in a strange order so that
your eyes are encouraged to go and look
at the ones that are new and one of the
ones that is new it is CN TK our
computational network toolkit and
there's a talk about that at the summit
so I'm going to spend the next few
slides just looking it's and
highlighting some of these projects so
the computational network toolkit is for
mission-critical AI research and the
idea here is that how do you measure
how well a project is doing in the open
source domain how do I measure it as a
project leader of my initiative well one
of the ways I can do it is to go and
look on github and github gives you a
lot of statistics sometimes it's a bit
irritating because those of you who are
great guitar people will know that the
statistics only go back two weeks and if
you forget to go and look at something
every two weeks you then miss out on
some statistics but anyway this one
you'll see is that it has had mergers
proposed and closed issues very very
recently and I only took this a pull
yesterday so we'll see that it had an
interesting merge which was called the
bug fix on grayscale images are now
assumed by default if the number of
channels blah blah blah so everybody can
see what's going on with a project
brilliant all right and in particular
the person who submitted that can see
that and that is now been fixed and
merged into the main stream there's a
proposed one here which says sublinear
memory of optimization on resnet
interesting proposal and maybe that will
be merged later on so all of this is
public and it's public for the team and
public for people code contracts is a
much older project code contracts is a
language agnostic way to express coding
assumptions in.net so this is a way of
making your programs more secure and
it's an active developer community for a
long time managed by mike barnett in
microsoft
and it's been moved over to the
mainstream of visual studio so code
contracts is now in visual studio if you
get visual shooter you get code
contracts so it's one of those pieces of
open source inside he has another piece
of way that you can find out how well is
the project dueling in open source you
can look at the contributions now you
can see that it around about this time
that we're looking at it had closed on
40 I have a manager and one of his
little sayings is is that a big number
it's 40 a big number and initially I was
thrown by such a question so you have to
go back and think about it is is that a
big number well it is a big number
because if it was 4,000 you wouldn't be
able to deal with them 40 is a big
number of contributions at any one day
and that's fantastic to have that kind
of people contributing in fact there are
studies that have shown that if you have
an active a project like this you can
actually forgo having to to developers
that you would otherwise have to pay for
in the company just by leveraging and
using the open source community as and
of course you're giving back to the open
source community in other ways and down
below you can see that the source code
has had 437 commits and so many branches
and so on and so on Daphne some of you
might have heard of Daphne Daphne is a
programming languages programming
language with a verifier this is also a
very mature project it was open source
right from the beginning
and it was on a different repo not
github it was on codeplex run BAM wrist
and leno and he spent a lot of time
making sure that Daphne would run on
different platforms in fact five
platforms so if you go to Daphne com so
yes that'll work Daphne calm you'll be
able to download it for whatever
computer you're running he's now since
moved it over to get up and you can once
again see that these are graphs from
codeplex and he's got about 40
contributors going at any one time he
has some main contributors there's a
post grad student at imperial college
but we all almost want to give a medal
to because the student has contributed
so much to the project another thing
that's interesting about open source
software or about any kind of software
is that you can make it run in a browser
and this was pioneered by projects like
Daphne and Microsoft is very proud that
we can do this so instead of having to
download software put it on your
computer ensure that it runs and so on
which can be daunting for people you
could try it out by just opening your
browser and then checking that it runs
and seeing whether you like the
experience so a lot of software which
comes out of this particular group in
Microsoft runs this way that's called
rods for fun and there it is r is e rise
for fun and that particular screenshot
comes from deftly in rise for fun touch
develop is another one and there's going
to be part of touch develop will also be
in the research showcase and the BBC
micro bit it was created for apps on
phones tablets laptops and so on as lang
specifically designed for using your
finger on all of these devices many
years ago and that was led by tomball
and it's now moved over to these little
chips but you're going to be able to see
and use and the history of that one was
interesting it wasn't open source and
there was no intention to open source it
but we wanted to have it in a in a
system in the USA called hour of code
you might have heard it it was a
fantastically organized and publicized
event with the ACM even President Obama
was promoting it for children to learn
to code but they would only put projects
on the website if there were open source
so he said all right we'll open source
it however the project itself doesn't at
the moment actively accept contributions
you can look at the code and you can
branch from it but you it's it's not
accepting contributions perhaps you can
discuss that with Jonathan and I might
be wrong at the moment but that was hard
was a while back and it runs on any
device it also runs on your browser and
that's a great thing and one of the
other things here is it has its own
urban repository so it runs of the cloud
and it has its own little cloud place
where all its own language scripts run
and you can see how many they are which
is enormous so it has at the moment 157
Forks when i took this probably more now
so people have forked it off now this is
a very big project it's called Project
aliens it's headed up by one of our
distinguished scientists called full
Bernstein
and it's a distributed interactive
application model for virtual actors now
that sounds very formal in fact this is
the brains behind the computer game
called halo and some of you or maybe
your children or someone have run halo
and it's automatically deployed in the
cloud and that Heather of course is a
major revenue base for Microsoft but
inside it the streaming part is open
source so you can go and look at how it
works and you can use the same streaming
base if you want to for your things and
you can see that when i took this clip
here they were 11 authors and they were
not all in microsoft because i know that
the team is two people at the moment
they were three ones left there to left
so there we have 11 people from all over
the world contributing f-sharp was
referred to in the introduction the
difference in f-sharp is that it is a
project that was open sourced right from
the beginning done sign who's in our
cambridge lab said i'm going to have
this language it's going to be open
source and then it became so well used
and so mature that they created what's
called a foundation and they moved it
out of Microsoft into the foundation
microsoft store supplies f sharp as part
of its languages but the foundation
looks after it and it has community
projects it runs workshops does all of
these things which foundations do so
there's such a huge community around
this that runs itself mots allah is
another one in another part of the world
that has its own foundation as well
eclipse has a foundation so very mature
open
source projects move that way and
finally Madoka I said I was going to
come to documents Madoka is something I
really think you should take a look at
it is a markdown processor which runs in
the cloud and it enables you to duel a
tech type document processing but in the
cloud and with other people all working
on the same document it's beautifully
tooled you can use different repos you
can use Dropbox you can use github you
can use a sure to store your projects
your documents and it's multi-platform
run on anything as it's sorted out it's
written in a specific type of computer
language called coker with Donlin as the
leader there and it's also open a source
and it's nice thing about it is it's
open to extension hi modularity so if
you want to add chemistry or physics
modules to this they are already quite a
few modules but if you wanted to add
more to be really easy to do it has over
2,000 new users in a week and very high
usage already it's getting a big user
base here so with all of that we decided
then one of the things we were going to
do is find out whether students would
like this kind of project open source
students like it and so we ran a
challenge this year to see if students
up there would be able to use these
projects and just to do a bit of
advertising these were some of the
students who won the prod won the
challenge which was announced two weeks
ago so they had a lot of money in prizes
they got 15,000 between them and the
winners
use the following project so there was
dssm Microsoft cognitive services which
I think there's also going to be a talk
about here it used to be called Project
Oxford XIII which is a verifier language
and C and D K so these were the popular
projects with these students and they
came from all over the world and did
fantastic work on the open source
projects finally this is my summary if
you want to have open source you can do
it in different ways and you can have
external input that forces you to go
open source you can have single Reapers
or more repos you can have a push to a
foundation and so on versions for all
platforms I've mentioned you can ship
with major platforms and inside major
platforms timing is not important you
can go open source at different times
but the main thing is you need
communities of developers and that is
where you all come in so I hope then in
the projects in the research showcase
that are open source you'll perhaps talk
more deeply to the sea the developers
who are out there and ask them about and
see whether you can contribute and work
with us through this mechanism and we'd
be delighted to have you thanks
very nice to thank you we have a few
minutes for questions does anybody have
anything they want to start off with I
know it's early oh good hello good
morning thanks for your presentation I
was curious about the bubble where
Moodle appears together with Microsoft
could you please talk about initiatives
from Microsoft regarding educational
tools and maybe open source those
regarding that subject Microsoft has
many educational tools now obviously
there are the ones which assists
everybody in education such as one note
and the office platform and so on then
there are the more serious ones which
are for programming so are you which
ones are you intending in the inner
presentation that their burrows are the
education yeah with mud mud oh yeah okay
gotcha so the educational tools are the
ones which are there for helping with it
with coding so let's take for example
touch develop that would be one of the
typical ones that's listed under there
and the idea would be that this is
something new something fresh and we
interested extremely interested in
finding out how other people degree in
education and in academia would want to
use that and through the open source
model they might be able to extend it
with us so that that is part of it I
think the best thing is if you come to
the research showcase
and I can explore more of those with you
and show them to you good good question
is there any particular license which is
the most used one for Microsoft openly
projects yes in fact I have the picture
here so this is the spectrum of licenses
which is a worldwide diagram of open
source taken from github actually and
the big blue thing up at the top there
is the MIT license and that is the one
that's recommended now within Microsoft
to use the next one down below is the
the GPL we don't recommend that one in
Microsoft as much and the reason is here
the permissive ones are the ones we
recommend more which means that you can
attribute in other words you recognize
when you send out the code you say I got
this code from this place and when you
use it you must also say you got it from
this place but the restrictive ones are
like the GPL ones and and we find those
very difficult to work with so Microsoft
Works much more with the MIT good one
more
thank you it's oh no my students had
been interns that microsoft research and
one common complaint is that they were
in allowed to use open source software
in their project so that has policy
change and in general how is the use of
open source in Microsoft projects with
that Microsoft Research and they went
allowed to use it yeah yeah they weren't
allowed to use open source a bit because
they were afraid of some sort of a
contamination oh yeah the coat that they
were developing so what what is
important to know is that there is a
process by which we even if you go back
here once you incorporate open source
within your own project you have to make
sure that that is identified forever
right and the soul I think that that
process has is handled by our release
team by our open source team and it is a
large team of people who ensure that
Microsoft or any company would do this
Microsoft's not unique that would ensure
that when anything then goes outside the
company we can't get sued by not having
the correct licenses around all the
pieces of software so it's very likely
than for numerous reasons depending on
the size of what your students are doing
that it might have been better to write
it themselves or because of time
constraints because I have to say that
going through this process is at least a
six week process but it's worthwhile
because once you've done it you've got
it
but it might well have been that the
owner of whatever was going on felt that
it you know the wadded up and said let's
not use the open source here but it
would not have been a decision that
would have been anti open source it
would have been made for other reasons I
suspect yeah or maybe the that was
awhile back and now we're in a newer
mode that's great Thank You Judith I'm
going to go ahead and wrap it up there
let's please give her another warm
welcome earth thank you